c'est au petit matin que les députés ont
adopté définitivement la loi sur
l'avortement je dis bien définitivement
car on a finalement renoncé à remettre à
l'essai pour cinq ans la loi et surtout
son application
et cela en dépit des avertissements
solennelle de michel debré par exemple
qui le premier jour du débat regrettait
la banalisation de l'avortement
maintenant la loi est votée il lui reste
encore à être confirmée par le sénat
mais de toute façon à l'évidence la loi
ne réglera pas les problèmes de
conscience de chacun devant une décision
aussi grave et elle suscite cette loi
naturellement de vives réactions chez
les adversaires de l'avortement
on voit d'ailleurs quand leur âme et
conscience les députés de la majorité
ont été très partagés
la loi a été adoptée par 271 voix contre
201 ont voté pour les socialistes et les
communistes sans exception mais
seulement 69 députés de la majorité 45
udf sur 121 et 24 rpr seulement sur 154
quelques modifications ont été apportées
à la loi pendant le débat jakin collins
cette loi comme celle de 1975 permettra
à toute femme qui se considèrent en
situation de détresse de demander un
avortement
celui ci devrait être pratiquée par un
médecin et en milieux hospitaliers
publics ou privés le délai de dix
semaines de vue la conception est
maintenu la femme devra se soumettre à
deux entretiens séparés de sept jours
destiné à l'informer sur les
conséquences de son acte et observer
deux jours supplémentaires de réflexion
entre le deuxième entretien et
l'avortement
un dossier guide lui sera remis
contenant la liste des organismes
susceptibles de l'aider
le directeur du centre d'interruption de
grossesse devra se faire remettre et
garder pendant au moins six mois et
attestation justifiant qu'elle a
satisfait à ces consultations
l'avortement ne sera toujours pas
remboursé par la sécurité sociale les
mineurs célibataire devront encore avoir
l'autorisation de leurs parents mais
elles donneront leurs consentements en
dehors de la présence de ceux ci les
médecins garde la liberté de refuser de
faire des avortements
mais ils devront dans ce qu'a indiqué à
la femme l'adresse d'un centre qui
pratiquent les interruptions de
grossesse des commissions dead à la
maternité seront installés
toutes les grandes villes ou près des
centres médico sociaux et des bureaux
dette sociale
les sanctions frappant les médecins qui
pratiquent les avortements illégaux sont
sérieusement aggravées
enfin une délégation parlementaire sera
constituée dans chaque assemblée pour
informer le sénat et l'assemblée de la
politique et des problèmes de la
natalité
en résumé ce qui change vraiment et que
ces dispositions sont à présent
définitive du moins le seront elles
lorsqu'elles auront été adopté par le
sénat qui doit les examiner à son tour
très prochainement